Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number six of my road to one bill
series. Uh today we're starting off
right from last episode with our
crawling hands task. And uh the focus of
this episode is 100% going to be range.
And yeah, let's get started. Okay, so
like I said, we're going to be focusing
mainly on range today. Uh we want to get
it high up um because eventually we
would like to do Zorra. Now um we're
just about done our crawling enhance
task. Not the greatest slayer task, but
not the worst. And we're just starting
training some slayer as well because we
would like to get broadb bolts
eventually. But I think we're going to
move on some rails because this is
rather slow. So our next task was hop
goblins which again not really too bad.
We're just about to hit 35 range here.
Uh we're using these iron knives which
uh are pretty quick. They're definitely
a little bit better than the arrows um
for the early levels. Um but I think
we're going to try out some other items
as well just to kind of judge for
ourselves what the best experience is.
Um so yeah, there's 35 range. So, I was
actually doing some reading and I heard
that iron knives are actually kind of a
rip and you should actually go for
darts. Um, so we're going to try selling
off our iron knives and apparently I can
buy myithil darts which do more damage
as well as have the exact same attack
speed um for cheaper. Yeah. So, we can
see the myithal darts are only 52 and
the iron knives were 80 and I believe or
sorry 64. Uh, but I believe they still
do more damage. So, yeah, we'll give
these a try. It's a little hard to tell
on these hobgoblins. Um I they're
definitely doing more damage. I have a
higher max hit for sure. Um but uh the
XP per hour is um a little bit better,
but not crazy difference, but at the
same time, it was much cheaper anyway.
Um so yeah, we just hit 39 range and
yeah, we'll see where we can go from
here. I think we're just about a slayer
level as well. Um which is good. It's
going to take a while to get to 55
slayer. It's very slow experience,
especially when I have this shitty
ammunition I'm using. But um until I
find a better place to train, I might as
well just train slayer because I'm going
to need it anyway and it's really really
slow. Um so there we go. We're just
about to hit the last hobgoblin which
will get us to um 20 something slayer.
Let's see. 28. So yeah, pretty good. And
there's level 40 range. We can now
finally wear the uh green dragon hide.
So we'll definitely go back and buy a
pair of that. Uh the snake skin just
looks awful to me, so I'm kind of be
happy to upgrade. Okay, so let's buy our
green dragon hide. Um the
um range attack bonus is definitely much
better on this. Uh luckily we've already
done dragon slayer, so we can wear it
all. Uh which is nice. And uh yeah,
hopefully we won't look like complete
[__] once we get this. Okay, let's have
a look. Um oh, I [__] God, I look pretty
bad still. Okay, so we want to start
doing animal magnetism. Um, but we will
need Ernest a chicken done, which is a
really annoying quest. So, let's get
this done. Okay, we are pretty much done
the quest. This quest took quite a long
time for being a very low-level quest.
It doesn't require any fighting or any
skills, but it's actually really
annoying trying to find items. Probably
took me 25 minutes, and it really should
have taken only like a minute or two,
but there we go. Four quest points, 300
gold. Pretty sweet. Okay, so we're here
at the sand crabs now. Um, I am getting
quite a bit better experience here and I
can AFK here for about 10 minutes
without having to actually touch my
character. There's 45 range. Um, it's
going very quickly. We're still using
the mythal darts. I think we're going to
try the Dorian crossbow in a minute here
to see what XP rates are actually
better. Okay, so we've been using the
Dorian crossbow for a couple levels now,
and it's definitely slower, but the
ammunition is dirt cheap. I would say at
the level I'm at right now, I'm getting
about 5k XP an hour slower than the
mythal darts, but um the mythal darts
cost about 100 50 to 100k. Maybe not
that much, but quite a bit hourly to
use. Um so I think it might be worth it
to use the darts later on. Okay, so
we're just about to hit 50 range here at
the sand crabs again. There we go. Uh so
we can now equip the AA's accumulator.
Uh which is pretty nice. Um but we still
have to do the quest animal magnetism.
So, we'll go ahead and do that quickly.
We decided to wait until we were 50 to
do it cuz I don't know, can't equip it
before then, so no point of doing it.
And some guy offered me 54 and he
canceled it. Some guy just offered me
like 54 Halloween masks. Uh, no donation
for me today, I guess. Okay, so I think
we have all the items for animal
magnetism. Um, our inventory is pretty
packed. Mainly, that's just the stuff
you need for uh the ecto tokens, but um
yeah, I think we're good to go and let's
get this started. Okay, so once again,
the fair rings are just so useful. Uh,
teleports to Mortm just like right there
up northeast right where our farming
runs are. And yeah, not a very hard
quest, but if you don't have the
teleports, it'll take quite a while. So,
know how I said that cut scene in Dragon
Slayer might be my favorite. I think
this one might actually be it. Um, this
guy just chasing around his chicken for
a few minutes and you're just kind of
watching him
struggle and I won't spoil it for you,
but this hilarious guy comes in and
helps. Man, I should just bop it with my
stick. This is taking
forever. Come on, let's go. And then the
guy comes back, failing some more. And
then this guy comes in with a freaking
DS axe, just axes the cow and the
chicken. and uh he's called cow killer
elite or something like that and
dead. But on the plus side, you get your
chicken. So yeah, it was all worth in
the end. Okay, so we're at the ecto
fungus now. Uh we're just getting the
ecto tokens we need to buy the uh undead
chicken. And that's the hardest part of
the quest done for sure. Okay, so we're
pretty much done here. We're just going
to complete the quest. And there we go.
A couple thousand crafting experience,
fletching experience, slayer experience.
pretty random, but um and we got slayer
level. So, we're level 29 and 37 wood
cutting, but most importantly of all, we
got the AAS accumulator, which will pick
up arrows for us, as well as gives the
rest uh the best range bonus in the cape
slot. So, that's pretty exciting. Okay,
so we're at the good old sand crabs
again. And here we're going to stay
until 61 range. Um not going to play too
much today, but damn it, I want to get
my range level to 61 so we can go kill
some dragons, start getting some money
for our range training pretty much. Um,
so we've kind of decided to do the
Dorian crossbow for now because um,
while the mythal darts are definitely
the best option for value, like the best
per XP, I would guess. U, but we're
cheap, we don't have a lot of money, and
we're going to be AFKing here for a
while. So, it was kind of adding up
buying all the mythical darts. And yeah,
we'll come back when we hit 61 range.
Okay, we are just about to do it. We
have been AFKing here all day. We just
come back every 10, 15 minutes. Uh,
reset the aggressiveness. And this dick
here keeps taking my spot, but doesn't
really matter anymore cuz we are just
about to hit 61 range. And one more shot
should do it. There we go. We can now
wield the rune crossbow. So, I think
we're going to go buy some ammo for
this. Um, let this guy a little bit
before we leave. And yeah, we'll go kill
some green
dragons. Okay, there's another farming
level, actually. So, um, that will give
us, uh, all our seeds have been
harvested now. Uh, which is pretty cool.
And I think we're getting another mill
in profit, which is always nice. Uh,
farming is definitely helping us fund
our account early on here. Yep. So,
another 1 mil in profit. You can see
here we're selling them for about 7k
each, and that gives us 1.8 mil, and we
bought the seeds for 800k. Would highly
recommend this if I haven't already.
Okay, so we got the rune crossbow and
some myithal bolts we're going to use.
My bolts were kind of expensive, but not
too bad. And yeah, let's go kill some
green dragons. Okay, we got killed.
[__] Uh but uh we got uh all the Renard
sold and we're not really risking much
at all. So it's not that big a deal. We
only killed like 24 dragons. Um try to
get PKed a couple times. So we're just
going to have to be a little wary of
this and pay more attention, but um I
think we can do it. So we're going to go
back and kill some more. Okay, so here
we're at the green dragons.
Unfortunately, somebody ped my looting
bag, so good for him. Uh but yeah, we
kill them pretty quickly. Um with the
looting bag, we should be able to get at
least one full inventory. Uh which is
pretty decent. I'm hitting 18s and 19s
with the ranging potion on. So, it's a
good level to start. And um yeah, let's
see how many of these we can actually
kill uh before we get pked
again. So, it turns out about 100. Um
definitely this one guy kept trying to
PK me, but he did not manage to kill me.
I was literally talking with some guy
cuz I wanted to finish my conversation
with him and this guy just kind of whail
on me, hitting tens and 15s and
whatever. But, um yeah, it's not too
hard to get away. It's just a pain in
the ass really. kind of a waste of time
for both of us. Uh so we're going to do
another farm run, but we will hit up the
dragons a little bit later, I think.
Okay, so we decided to finish our slayer
task of desert lizards, which is a
really bad task. So if you can block
them, I would definitely do it. The
slayer XP is bad. You have to use this
stupid ice box them every time you want
to kill them. Um so you can see this
lizard like okay, bam, should be dead.
But it actually has one HP and then you
have to use the ice box on it and then
it kills it. So it's a really
frustratingly annoying task. Plus, you
need water skins. Uh, so I would
recommend not doing it, but we're going
to do it anyway cuz we don't really have
any points and uh yeah, nothing we can
do about it really. Okay, there we go.
The task is pretty much done. Um, so
yeah, we're doing this slayer early. Um,
mainly to get some points saved up so we
can cancel some tasks tasks like these.
Um, so that's pretty much why we're
doing it. And we want to get the range
training as well. Okay, so let's see
what our next task is. is it's going to
be ice giants, which is definitely
better. U but we'll see how this goes.
Okay, so the ice giants really are not
too bad. Um they definitely hit hard and
there is a safe spot, but uh the ice
warriors can get into it, but the ice
giants can't. But we did hit actually 64
range, so the range levels are going
very quickly. Um just wielding this bow
all the time is really helping us get
our range levels up there. Our end goal
is going to be uh 75 range for the toxic
blowpipe and to get some Zoro
requirements. Okay, so we're done our
task of ice giant. So, let's see what
our next task will be. Um, we got 33
slayer from that. So, it was actually a
pretty good task for experience. And our
next task is the [__] desert lizards
again. H I need to block these as soon
as possible pretty much. Um, but I mean
it doesn't take very long. So, we'll go
do it for the uh points. Okay, that
should be our last desert lizard. Um, it
did only take 20 minutes, but still just
an awful task. I'm going to block this
one as soon as I can. And yeah, I think
we'll do another task. Uh, but we're
getting a little tired of Slayer. Okay,
let's see what our next task is going to
be. 15 cave slimes. What the [__] is
that? Um, okay. Well, still it'll only
take 5 minutes. I mean, it's annoying
task. It's awful experience, but it'll
only take us 5 minutes and we'll get
some points for it. So, let's go do it.
Okay, so we're back. Let's get our next
task in. 109 banshees. That's not so
bad. But I think that's where we're
going to end it for today, guys. As much
as I'd love to keep doing all these
shitty slayer tasks, um I think I'm
going to call it for today. We got quite
a bit of progress done on our account.
We got from like 30 to 65 range. Um not
the longest episode, but a lot of play
time. I hope you guys enjoyed. Um again,
if you like the series, please drop a
like rating down below and I'll see you
guys in the next episode.
[Music]